bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation
dollars contre roanne la guerre des
monnaies a commencé dans la galaxie
monétaire la chine contestent la
suprématie du billet vert américain l'
empire du milieu ne manque pas d'atouts
pour lancer son offensive et notamment
son avance dans la numérisation de sa
monnaie pour en parler je reçois michel
aglietta professeur émérite à
l'université paris-x nanterre son
dernier livre coécrit avec goût au bail
et camille macaire vient de paraître aux
éditions odile jacob
il a pour titre la course à la
suprématie monétaire à l'épreuve de la
rivalité sino-américaine
bonjour michel aglietta un jour aller le
dollar s'est encore la devise clé on est
d'accord le dollar est une des espèces
déclinante inclus entre et on s'en
aperçoit parce que pas mal de banques
centrales dans le monde fin de pays
recherchent à diversifier les monnaies
dans lesquelles les investissent ce qui
veut dire que un certain nombre de
monnaies qui sont donc des monnaies
convertibles uns
deviennent intéressantes parce qu'elle
permet de dix ans un arbitrage
rendement/risque des pays qui essaye
d'avoir de vrais de vrais mona oui plus
important que de passer par le dos à
chaque fois par le dollar il y fait un
déclin du dollar progressif et on s'en
aperçoit depuis quelques années c'est à
dire que vous avez
lisons par rapport au début du siècle
dollar avait 70 % 1 des réserves
mondiales il a descendu vers 55 à qui ça
profite tuer le roux le profil bas
l'euro ça valait encore beaucoup plus si
on ne pourra peut-être venir un euro
digital qui est quand même des idées a
lieu à partir de
2024 quelques à l'euro deviendra une
monnaie très autonome et qui aura un
pouvoir si vous voulez d'expansion
internationale du fait que l'union
européenne a des liens avec l'afrique a
des liens avec le proche-orient et c'est
donc un euro digital disons donnerait
une autonomie à leur a beaucoup plus
importante qu'elle n'a sauf que c'est le
roi le ikhwan qui a plus d' avance que
le i dollars et lui leur levier sur leur
one la plus parce que le processus de
rechercher cette monnaie digital
s'est produit dès 2014 ils ont et ont
lancé les choses 2014 ça a pris un
certain temps si vous voulez province
par province aéré chinois ils font pas
mal de concertation de l'approximation
d'expression est ce que c'est pas ben on
avance on recule mais en 2022 s'est fait
complètement c'est à dire qu'avec les
jeux olympiques d'hiver le iguane est
devenu une monnaie sur l'ensemble du
pays pour que cela soit clair pour votre
livre vous le dit bien l'objectif de
pékin s'est pas de remplacer le monopole
du dollar par le one c'est un système
multipolaire oui alors ce que ce qui se
passe mais avant ce qui rend
multipolaire le système c'est
l'invention qui est une invention
général l'a1 de la monnaie digitale de
banques centrales la maladie vital de
banque centrale est venu en opposition
au projet de ce qu'on appelle les
biftecks 1 c'est-à-dire des possesseurs
de plateforme internet qui ont cherché à
prendre en charge le système de paiement
mais une et devenir de ce qu'on appelle
des fintec - là évidemment le projet
libre à a été un bon chef d'un important
de noter là et donc
la mona digitale de banques centrales
parce que la monnaie fondamentalement
est une entité politique publique
souveraine ou et ça je le dis depuis 40
ans si vous voulez
livre avec andré orléan un brin de donc
c'est la mode à digital de banque
centrale permet à la banque centrale
donc elle a un cash digital qui remplace
le cash traditionnels et qui permet à la
banque centrale de contrôler l'usagé
international de 120 de ses résidents
qu'ils voudraient si vous voulez sortir
sa monnaie pour l'amener en monnaie
étrangère puisqu'il permet de le
contrôler et là c'est la propriété
vraiment de la monnaie digitale de
banque centrale c'est à dire que le code
digital est incorporé dans un protocole
un protocole informatique il permet à la
banque centrale se contrôler ce qui est
évidemment très important ça veut dire
que la banque centrale peut éviter le
sort des fuites
de sa monnaie à l'étranger parce qu'elle
contrôle l'usagé qu'en font ses propres
résidents lorsque lorsqu'il la sorte et
c'est en cela que les chinois de la
vence alors les chinois ont une avance
dans ce sens que ce iguane moins quand
on est déjà opérationnelle complètement
alors que le euros
ça qui va nous conduire à un euro du
zidane est en cours de préparation et le
lido l'or alors le dollar a hésité
longtemps je dirais oui pascal au régime
honni elle est liée à la devise cris
l'existence de monet digitale de banque
centrale routière un système monétaire
international symétrique et à cri
crucial et par conséquent un système de
coopération institutionnelle entre de
l'ensemble des émetteurs de monnaie
digital auquel cas la suprématie du
dollar en tant pis guémon un jugement
bien elle elle est forcément mis en
cause puisque le principe de la devise
play serait mis en cause fondamentale
donc de la vence du ikhwan mais en même
temps retard sur la réglementation et
l'encadrement des marchés financiers en
chine même ce qui attire pas forcément
les capitaux étrangers voulant bien sûr
ce qui se passe c'est que en chine il ya
un retard
c'est-à-dire le processus
d'internationalisation de la finance
rencontré des difficultés dans le temps
en particulier avec une tentative
d'avancer très vite en 2015 qui a
entraîné une hémorragie
johann duhoo relais et donc ils sont
aperçus que le processus devait être un
processus beaucoup plus contrôlée est
beaucoup plus long en quelque sorte donc
ce processus est en route mais il a
rencontré une autre difficulté bien sûr
ces difficultés étaient liées un lin la
pandémie en matière 2020 c'est à dire
que
déjà en 2003 et est amené à faire une
énorme si vous voulez avancer budgétaire
pour essayer d'aller à l'encontre de
cette de cette crise du muntu donc là
cette avancée budgétaire a eu comme
conséquence bien sûr de créer de la
dette d'ancrer la dette des entreprises
migrent éléments et en 2020 bien sûr il
ya eu la question de la pandémie la
question de la pandémie a aussi posé de
gros problèmes
entre les deux vous avez une crise
immobilière et vers grandes étendues de
parler de divers grands bus la très
grande entreprise et vers grandet et par
conséquent vous avez à la fois une dette
des entreprises manufacturières qui la
plus haute au monde vous dit dans le
livre pour ce qui est de la date d'un
opus magnifique milliards oui et puis le
problème immobilier et donc depuis 2017
2018 la chine et cei le gouvernement
chinois he said un faire pression
notamment sur
un certain nombre d'acteurs un hedge
fund et ses 1 1 qui ne sont pas des
banques standard mais qui sont des
acteurs qui font crédit le shadow
banking comme on dit
pour faire très vite et faire en sorte
que la dette soit maîtrisé mais cette
maîtrise de la bête entraîne évidemment
une plus grand ralentissement qu'il ne
l'avait pensé
de la
du développement de leurs grands marchés
obligataires alors l'objectif vie
l'objectif de la chine c'est donc un
multilatéralisme des monnaies est-ce
qu'on peut le faire dans ce monde là qui
est en train de se fracturer alors qu'on
aurait besoin au contraire de plus de
cohésion de cohérence pour lutter contre
le changement climatique
c'est en effet
le gros problème en cause puisque chaque
monnaie digital
a son propre code informatique qui lui
est incorporé oui il faut donc pour
avoir une monnaie internationale des
soit qu' une monnaie l'emportent sur
toutes les autres mais ça paraît très
peu probable
soit que ces monnaies se mettent
ensemble d'accords oui pour fabriquer
une monnaie mondiale commune alors il ya
une tentative de valises un tentative
une proposition qui a été faite par
l'ancien gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre mark carney ou qu'il a
faits au symposium de la fed et un
symposium de la fed de tous les ans au
mois d'août
en 2021 d'ailleurs qui est de dire il
est possible si on se met d'accord sur
le protocole une question de fabriquer
une monnaie digital synthétique mondiale
est en effet théoriquement c'est quelque
chose de possible à ce moment là vous
auriez une monnaie synthétique mondial
avec un protocole commun et en
conséquence la possibilité
d'avoir une cohésion du système
international pour faire face au danger
évidemment la transition écologique la
transition écologique à l'ensemble des
questions environnementales qui sont des
problèmes communs de la planète
lorsqu'on voit aujourd'hui notamment
avec la guerre une crème est-ce que
c'est pas une déconnexion d'un monde
d'un côté occidental et d'un mundo
l'autre côté oriental oui ces espaces
évidemment comme ça c'est à dire que
pour avoir ce que voulait mccarney il
fallait
nécessairement une
cohésion politique l'asthme est d'accord
politiquement pour avoir ça et la
maternelle dit pas comment politiquement
aujourd'hui les problèmes communs sont
possibles doit prendre en compte ces
problèmes communs mais dans un monde qui
est politiquement extrêmement divisée
donc ça c'est elle a en tout cas la
première solution théorique possible la
deuxième est peut-être en parler bien
sûr très rapidement c'est ben c'est
passer à un niveau supérieur
ben c'est la logique fondamentale du
livre c'est à dire avec
le fonds monétaire international
devenant le prétend internationale en
dernier ressort avec une monnaie qui est
vraiment fait pour faire ça ils sont les
droits de tirage spéciaux pour quelle
raison fondamentale parce que les droits
de tirage spéciaux ne sont pas la
contrepartie de la dette d'un pays mais
quand donc il n'ya pas d'hégémonie d'un
pull d'une devise clé dans les droits de
tirage spéciaux ce qui veut dire qu'avec
les droits de tirage spéciaux il est
possible de fabriquer une monnaie
commune mondiale mais mais il faut
évidemment que le fonds monétaire
international devienne à ce moment là le
prêteur en dernier ressort pour
l'ensemble de la planète merci beaucoup
michel aglietta pour vos réponses
l'entretien de l'intelligence économique
est terminée évidemment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur france 24
points comme au revoir
[Musique]